oui oui bonjour madame valberg
excusez-moi voulez que je me tue non
fait c'était au sujet de valbert but n
est pas facile
si la docile arrête ce sont des light
trop volés c'est calme a déjà envoyé
trois chauffeurs
ah bon vous allez m'aider à changer dès
demain mademoiselle valberg du chauffeur
je suis pas là pour changer vos draps ou
en alsace ça vous endurez de m'expliquer
ce qu'on vient de faire signer mais mais
n'est pas monté mes valises
je n'ai pas porté mes affaires comme
juste dire merci et bonne soirée
pourquoi nous avait raconté arsène kate
soit absolument moi qui vous conduisent
et vous pourquoi vous êtes revenu j'ai
pas le choix parce que j'ai une petite
fille de 10 ans et qui veulent un
avantage et pas de travail
sans quoi ça pue la colle à papier peint
vous savez les aldéhydes serveuse elle
porte j'adore et vous connaissez la
recette qui tous les parfums comme ça
c'est moi qui n'écrit c'est sa période
de gloire à l'époque on lui déroulé des
ponts d'or pour qu'elles signalent
parfois ça vous fait penser à quoi je
sais pas faites vous confiance un peu je
vais refaire du parfum vous feriez
pourquoi vous n'aurez pas quelques ont
ce métier parce que vous êtes doué
guillaume la serveuse par le seul
instant que vous avez le lever la tête
pour la regarder mais ils n'ont pas
qu'une odeur si vous n'êtes même pas
capable de dire deux mots juste deux
mots merci saint cricq
[Musique]